everything that we discovered in science
about the universe now and then imagine
going on an iasa trip and experiencing
what that feels like to be everything to
be like like a
toilet astronomers have detected a
mysterious blast of radio waves what
that have taken 8 billion years to reach
Earth W is it cuz like a star imploded
and then the aftermath goes imagine
tuning into it and all you hear
is oh yeah unfortunately is not like
that you [__] IA [__] R not even I
dude it might be sobs right fast radio
burst we've been listening to fast radio
burst for a long time right for for many
years we don't know their Origins um the
first FB was discovered in 2007 and
since then hundreds of these little
quick Cosmic flashes have been detected
coming from distant points all across
the universe but we don't know what it
is we don't know the origin we know that
it's a radio burst it's not like a blown
up star we don't know I think it is like
a sun fart or something I think it is
could be a sun fart we don't know is
that called a solar flare what else
could it be Ken it's called a sun fart
dude it could be uh other civilizations
blasting out radio waves all the way so
we can get it yeah sending deep house
through
the Swedish House Mia through the yeah
dude space sending
MCO what is a Dr it's the
rude that would be sick though like it
was like some other like thing that's
like trying to blast like they're seeing
if there's other living beings outside
and then we're receiving it and then
we're listening it's
going sucks but it's crazy that's like 8
million years ago right yeah explor
space billion what if it's like Morse
code but they're saying help me but
we're taking it as oh that's sick Bro
these guys are sick that's very sad if
it's a billion year old distress call
help me help me cuz that could be like
us imagine we get into like World War II
we have a nuclear war boom right and
then they flies back over there and
they're like oh [__] there's a nuclear
war over there but by the time they come
over it's [__] torched yeah that's
realistic what if all we ever achieve as
a species is that we just sent a bunch
of [__] radio shows into the universe
and and and TV shows and that's it like
War of the Worlds R all we do yeah cuz
like think about that like right in the
cosmic scale yeah we're we're beaming
this [__] all over the place but then if
like if we blow ourselves up that's all
we're ever going to be seen for they'll
never know about anything they'll never
know about the Statue of Liberty or like
the way we lived or anything they'll
just hear like a bunch of [__] about
about our culture what do you want what
do you think our culture should be
remembered by or our life American or
the Earth culture Earth let's start with
America and then let's go Earth uh
PornHub Tool Time honestly that's
probably a big big player if they saw
our servers right now they'd be like
these animals really like to mate they
they like to reproduce they like to
watch other people mate yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah we like to watch
people it is kind of funny but then that
that's how we survive as an organism
right it's like you got to want to like
keep but then but then apparently
watching others mate causes less mating
yeah bro if you think about it we're
such cucks we watch bees [__] what right
we want dude don't scientists do oh oh
you're right you're talking about not us
you watch any nature documentary we're
watching things [__] almost every time
we're fascinated by it yeah we love it
can't stop watching it when my dog
starts humping it's hilarious the Earth
too is like we have like what 20 30,000
years of just like ancient [__] that we
don't even know happened right the
pyramids and stuff right so it's like we
have all of that plus up to date now if
you were an alien how would you even
begin to like know how the human culture
and everything is cuz it's changed so
[__] much dude you know what would be
sick if we got discovered by aliens but
all that was left over was like our
music like The our electronics and our
music and all the art that we left
behind so when they see it it's like
they're tapping they're tapping into
like the music that we used to listen to
as a civilization and then to see how
they would react to that like that would
be yeah but would it be like Swedish
House Mafia would it be like
you
remember infinite amount yeah but you
remember Guardians how like he's like
hey check out my [__] Walkman and
she's like what the [__] is this
Florence Against the Machine yeah or
something like that let that coochie
breathe that's but imagine if that's
what we were known for like our our
music taste you know sounds like a
bummer dude sounds like one of the
things we would be known for cuz that's
on the golden record like that we sent
out but you know what's crazy is that we
can hear frequencies at a certain point
right what if it gets to a group of
aliens that don't register the same
sound so like for example like and like
yeah whatever like they can they can
hear a different frequency that we can't
yeah and then so like or like dogs too
yeah they can hear other stuff that we
can't so I'm like what if it just goes
out but then they don't have the same
tools that we do like they don't see the
same way they might be blind you know
what I mean like kind of like whale
language cuz they're
extremely and we just think it's a bunch
of whack sounds
that's what I like about the the ant the
anthill theory that like anything that's
so Advanced that it could even see what
we're doing looks at it like it's so
nothing and they just go oh it's like
when you look at an anill you're not
trying to talk to them you just go oh
gross oh that's cool yeah because like
imagine being so Advanced that you could
literally watch at any time you're not
going to be that interesting can you
imagine that like we there's several of
us like anthills so like there's other
planets that they know and they just see
it as like oh that's another ant that's
another ant my theory is that there's
always weirdos in society who have ant
farms that's pretty weird there's got to
be someone that's fascinated by the
majority probably is like e whatever and
then some of them are like I think it's
kind of
cool so maybe that's that one alien we
keep seeing the [__] pill thing the
Tic Tac he's the weirdo like no these
guys are kind of sick I like that that's
actually kind of a tight theory that
makes a lot ofense he wants to a closer
look cuz of course right like like I
mean some sometimes like when when Joe
Rogan's going on on a topic I don't care
about I'm like you know what I mean like
it's just about preference it's about
like what what is what is it and he's
the most popular guy on Earth so he's
the most popular guy on Earth and
sometimes I'm like I had him out and
then we all do that so like what if you
know you're you're like I think I'm a
nerd about this particular subject and
nobody's really watching this stuff and
that's why there's videos on YouTube
with guys doing toy train stuff what if
we're like an aliens
planetarium like like you know how like
you watch a YouTube video and then you
just create like a world and then like
you have all the well not a world but
like fish tank and then a little fish
tank is going around and they don't know
that it's a human doing all this [__]
they're just like w I'm in a [__]
fish tank right so it's like what if we
are in an observing tank for some alien
kid and this is his video game dang when
you were on iasa oh let's go did you
ever did you ever have a realization of
like like what's the purpose of the
human race not purpose but more so like
perspective what's the perspective the
perspective is what you think your
reality is now that's not the only
reality that exists because what like
what were you before what were humans
and planet Earth before it became that
there's some sort there was some sort of
Consciousness or some sort of life that
first had to become this then to evolve
into this and then it became humans
eventually right based off of theory but
then what I saw was dude we were always
there since the beginning of time to the
end of time that Consciousness or life
is always there even if you're dead or
alive or whatever oh that's the
perspective that I saw that's why it
makes so you were an
amiba dude I felt like I was just a part
of everything you just were like the
universe is a tree like we are the
universe like because keep yeah yeah
because if you think about we all
inhabit space like we're all living
floating around space you know but then
you were a
toilet
can you answer him though um I no
comment I I cannot say yes or no CU then
you like to get peed on and that gets
weird yeah I don't want to open that up
cuz it's crazy like as big as a planet
is right yeah when you zoom out there's
actually way more space in space than
there our planets and you're like damn
what is this fast thing what's the whole
point what's holding it up so imagine
that right so imagine everything that we
discovered in science about the universe
now and and then imagine going on an
iasa trip and experiencing what that
feels like to be everything to be like a
part of like a toilet don't imagine it
just go was like to be a
b it's held up by a be that's why I
really I really love that that Rick and
mor episode where they find out that
like Rick created a whole universe just
to be the car battery of his car so that
it never dies and then they go inside
that universe and a dude in there did
the same thing with his car so it's like
infinite right so you see like the
infinite Loop of how everything is and
he tells him like dude simul you're just
a car battery and he's like what this
whole [__] world it's just the power
of your
car I mean that's kind of if the
simulation theory is real right like if
isn't that kind of funny that we're
playing um
GTA while if we are a similation being
played yeah it's like a game within a
game it dude I still kick your ass at
Halo I don't give up
a game within a game especially with a
civil war DLC let's go
[Music]
baby